ma'am how you doing I'm doing good good
what do you got going on in here you're
all over the road no I'm done yeah I got
you on video you're driving all over the
road so no everything f i just it the
light was red that this light was green
yeah so I
said but I'm fine I know but you keep
I'm not with this area yeah but you keep
you're swerving all over you somebody
said that you hit something yes no I
didn't anything anything you didn't hit
anything no okay we're going to need you
to take a step out of the car yeah but I
didn't do anything
okay
perfect is
ity put it in
for she smashed no no no I want you to
step
out yeah she definitely smell window H
all right step out
man' yeah look at the front of the
car no
think this is the passer by said he saw
the passer by was like she hit something
like boom Square yeah he said he she
almost flipped her car what you put he
said hey he was like I was I was she
probably came across and ran right over
he said he I was cuz I was parked facing
he he screamed over the meeting he goes
he's like this lady's PL he's like he's
like she almost flipped her car I didn't
realize that was you were behind her
when I was com down I think she had just
taken stuff cuz there's anex and stuff I
don't smell
alol yeah the Windex she owns the
cleaning
Shea oh okay and why is she coming back
this way I don't know all right ma'am
step out
yeah can I just get her her stuff can I
can I just get no I need you to step out
it's a biggy can I is I need you to step
out leave your dog in the car please
okay you're going to be testing here
leave the car leave the dog leave the
dog put the dog in the car
stop kill your lights yep so I'm
Sergeant so in Atlanta cins Police
Department okay now listen do you have
any do you have any problems with your
eyes or anything no you don't have any
problems with your eyes Okay do you wear
contacts no do you wear glasses no okay
just take one half step off the back of
your car okay we're going to have you
perform a field sobriety test okay I I
come down so I can understand because
it's my second language okay oh what do
you want to do take one step towards me
okay okay what I want you to do is stand
with your feet together like this okay
your arms down at your side okay like
this yes okay all right I want you to
stand stare right here look up at me
okay all right I want you to stare with
the T tip of my pen right here okay can
you see the tip of my pen yes okay I
want you to reach out and touch the tip
of my pen if you could see it touch
touch the tip of my pen all right I'm
going to move it right to left and up
and down you're going to follow it with
your eyes and your eyes only okay you're
not going to move your head at all yeah
all right okay all right I'm going to be
begin the
test don't move your
head highp speed chases we got a unruly
suspects I will kill that mothers me no
do it stay in the BL box I like it Kink
dramatic DUI I'mma pass everything that
she trying to do and shocking body cam
footage hey get on the go get on the
ground law and crime presents body cam
the place for real raw and WI police
videos you should have seen it it was
good it's on body camera I'll show it to
you catch the action and subscribe to
our new YouTube channel
[Music]
now keep following my pen it's over here
don't move your head at
all don't keep following my pen yeah I
you okay
don't move your
head okay keep your eyes I'm tip my pen
right
here okay relax all right this officer
is going to take you to the next two
tests okay okay this is offic for leel
all right good okay thank you just
listen to him for the first up you just
put your feet together teach me okay put
your feet together hands down at your
sides okay I have I have swaps on okay
that's okay yeah that's okay okay so
what do you want to do first I want you
to take your right foot you don't have
to do it yet all right just watch me
okay you're going to take your right
foot you're going to lift it up and
you're going to hold it 6 in off the
ground parallel like this okay and
you're going to stand like this until I
tell you to stop okay okay and then once
you stop stop I'll just tell you to stop
okay okay can I do it now yep when
you're ready whichever whichever foot
you feel better on it doesn't matter
which one doesn't matter what
foot you said until I tell you to stop
yeah I'm sorry I I I
misund flip flops is hard you can take
the more yeah do you want to do it
without them I don't know if it's better
no that's fine that's only my second one
so okay this one right whichever one you
want
okay
okay all right now I'm going to show you
another test
okay yeah so you're going to take and so
you know I have a bruise on on my a
bruise on your knee yeah okay all right
you're going to take nine steps okay
okay I'll count it for you when you do
it and you're going to walk Heel To Toe
how to do it watch me have watch me do
it and then I'll have you do it okay
okay so you're going to do one two 3 10
I went to nine I know I went and then
and then you're going to turn around
with your foot flat like
this and then you're going to do it
again
to nine okay so you're going to count
out loud to nine and then you're going
to turn around fo flat
again good okay to nine do you want to
do it with your flipflops on or off I
don't know what's better but whatever
you think is better sneakers sneakers
would be better but we got to work with
what we got yeah I'll try Okay Okay Okay
so heel a toe like this okay stand like
this for the beginning like that so
you're going to stand like this okay
okay
okay and then go whenever you're ready
you're going to go to nine you're going
to take nine steps and then turn around
St okay nine
steps
again again can I go again
how many did you do three oh you did
three steps yeah okay okay do do uh do a
few more steps
okay can I go again how many did you
do four you five five I didn't
count you
so demonstrate nine steps here look you
have to walk nine steps so one
2 3 4 5 6 7 8
nine turn around
okay what
one keep going
two keep going
three keep
going
four keep
8 9 turn around turn
around one
four I sa on my
clip three right
down
four
5 6
nine it's nine right why is nine why is
not 10 why is nine that's right all
right just do me a favor just turn
around yeah
okay just going to place you under
arrest okay why they're driving under
the
influence
[Music]
what you don't have to do like I'm not
going to do anything okay all right
sounds
good won't go too crazy okay hey hold on
hold
on all right I'm going to bring you to
the back of my car okay okay but my no
my dog ma'am just cooperate with this
officer real quick he's going to put you
in the back of his car okay you're under
arrest at this point we're going to take
care of your dog okay but I just want go
this way go this way please go this way
we're going to bring into the car I just
want to tell you okay we're going to go
right this way tell me tell me tell me
whatever you need this side
okay this
side where am I going have a seat right
in there no but which which place it's
too tight I'm just going to check your
pockets okay okay yeah it's too
tight it's too tight hey stop don't
twist your it's too tight it's cuz
you're moving a
lot I'm just going to check this pocket
okay okay you have anything in that
pocket no okay nothing else else just
have a seat in the car man stop twisting
your wrist around what are you reaching
for No I'm trying to sit down how am I
going to go ahead have a seat okay
I'm to buckle you in okay can you can
you make a
little
sure what about my dog we got your dog
yeah she's going to
come okay what kind of dog is it it's a
mix of p and shitu and so you know that
medications turn your turn your turn and
so you know the medications I have in
the car it it's prescribed to me okay
sounds good I I just want to let you
know it's prescribed to me all
right weren't you going
to yes I am going to why'd you turn back
around I didn't turn back around oh no
no I took the wrong way
okay I am fine
okay I don't drink I don't do anything I
just have anxiety and depression and I
take medication for that okay that's it
all right but I I I need to work
tomorrow
gotcha so and then my husband is going
to have to Pi me up mhm
okay and I just want to make sure I I
have to prove all this
prescription is my prescription that I
take okay yeah and I take with me
because I have pic a and what are you
prescribed okay all right we're going to
get back to this body cam in a second
but I want to take a minute to talk
about something else that happens all
the time workplace injuries if you get
hurt at your job whether it's a slip and
fall a mechanical failure negligence of
your co-workers something hits you
you're going to need a trusted law firm
in your corner enter Pon Le hockey
Giordano a firm that is a heavyweight in
the industry that wins all different
kinds of injury cases yes workplace but
also accidents Social Security
Disability injuries they have a track
record of recovering over $1 billion for
their clients and they have won over a
100,000 cases they have 250 years of
combined experience how amazing is that
so you can check out ponle hockey
Giordano at ponle hockey.com
LC body cam or you can pick up the phone
and call them at 833 669 4043 all right
let's get back to the body
cam I don't know why why I came to here
I don't I'm not familiar with this area
so I don't know to drive around around
town okay
all right I'm just going to I'm going to
read you your Miranda Rights
okay okay ready ma'am you have the right
to remain silent here's her
phone keys I'm putting in there all
right okay yeah what did they do
wrong I I'm I'm sorry I I don't mean to
be rude what did they do wrong I told
you we we arrested you for driving Under
the Influence did you take I'm going to
read you your rights okay here listen
just listen to me okay you have the
right to remain silent anything you say
can be used against you in court you
have the right to talk to a lawyer for
advice before we ask you any question
just keep listening to me you have the
right to a lawyer with you you have the
right to have a lawyer with you during
questioning if you cannot afford a
lawyer one will be appointed to you
before questioning if you wish if you
wish if you decide to answer questions
now without a lawyer present you have
the right to stop answering at any time
and how long do you how long yeah do you
understand the rights I I just read to
you yeah with these rights in mind do
you how long them saying ja with these
rights in mind do you still wish to
speak to me and how long you still wish
to talk to me after the rights what do
you mean you still wish to speak to me
after I just read you those words I just
want to know how long I stay in jail you
should be able to get out tonight okay
unless you have other charges no I don't
okay so then you should be right I I I
don't
okay and I'm sorry I don't mean to be
rude to you but I don't think because
people
people are not 100% Balan they are under
the influence I'm not drunk I don't
drink I don't do drugs I just take my
medication because I I need
them I
understand can I have my dog we have to
hold we you'll get your
dog why my cell phone we have it it's up
here it's in the car can I call my
husband well call him when we get to the
station I just don't bring like a a food
bag of medication with me what's that I
I don't bring a full bag of medication
with me I just bring the ones I need to
take and today I had a tough day
okay I've got used to uh drive around
here yeah because I never been here
before and and so I was taking I was
being careful and when I saw the green
light I
went okay but I wasn't all over the
place
okay and I don't drink I don't do drugs
I'm I'm not under the influence of
anything okay
Che
ow what's wrong on the Cuffs so I have
like
uh five medications that I take
last four
vitamins uh-huh and I don't take I have
to take them three times a day okay and
I don't take them the whole thing with
me because I don't need to have the the
full bag so I take some of me so he can
rest the day any case I have a panic
attack I can I can take care of myself
there okay CU I work in LBI and far away
from the hospital so sometimes I have a
panic attack I think I'm going to die
and I take and they help me okay so this
is this is my
prescription okay
yes uh uh my husband be keeping up
because I have to work tomorrow at 6 in
the morning
okay so can I get a
uber I'm sure that's not a problem once
we're all done here you can get whatever
you want to get out of here okay I'll
get a uber because I don't want to
bother my my my my my husband especially
after a day we had today
okay can't
5484 transport complete my mileage is 51
8757 I'm sorry um to be talking a lot
that's okay I am I am I am um
I a gentle person and I'm not aggressive
and this this uh how do you
call d is really hurting me okay I'm not
I'm not going to do anything to anybody
okay that's
good
oh that was you that why that was that
that was that why was nice I thought
there was the other guy which one the
one I don't like too much but you really
nice thank you you're
welcome the other guy wasn't so nice no
oh he's a nice he's a good man no he's a
good man but I like you better all right
can you take can you take this for me
what's that what am I taking the they
hurt me oh yeah they're going to come
off I'm not going to hurt anybody okay I
have to leave them on just for a little
bit and then I'm going to put you on the
bench okay so just step out okay can we
make this happen because I have to work
tomorrow yeah yeah we we'll get it
going slide on
out
all right
mhm just hang right
there my my eyes is my eyes is itching
okay do it uh when when we get the
handcuffs off okay
okay
why is that
puppy they got it they got the dogs
don't fall no it's not falling that
would be
terrible
okay all right thank you for being nice
and polite to me you're
welcome going to go in
here actually here we'll just hang out
out here for a
second there wrist hurt yeah it does
yeah
yeah here I'll switch you over put here
go this
way here come on come on
this
way wait for my
supervisor um do I have to pay for the
Uber or you guys pay for you'll probably
pay for the Uber can you guys pay and I
pay you guys later uh I don't think
so okay or you can get a ride home from
somebody
okay I didn't want to buy my family
that's all
yeah all right
what but I was just not used to that
area yeah I never drove there no I got
you so I was confused
uhhuh when I first moved from Brazil to
here I was confused I didn't know how to
drive and now from one place to another
I get confused to so I was like should I
go should I not go and then I saw I saw
green and I went yeah no yeah Green
Light you definitely go yeah that's good
that's the way it's okay Mia nobody is
going to hurt
you I'm want to switch it
soon okay ma' just separating
here I'll switch yep stay right there
yeah